hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to mind scanners so this
game
is um i hesitate to say it's like paper
please
but there's a lot of reviews that said
it was kind of like that but some people
were like you can't compare to that
either way it's about scanning people's
brains for normalcy and declaring them
whether they're sane or insane
and helping them along the way now i
don't know fully what that means
because it looked pretty complex but i
can guess greeting citizen
as you are well aware your daughter is
now in the care of the structure
she has been placed in quarantine at the
zignoca institute as she has shown signs
of a highly contagious mental illness
details of her condition are classified
but we assure you that she is in good
hands
for normality and the mind love
the structure thanks strucky
request to visit your daughter denied to
access the zignoca institute you must be
a mind scanner with a level three
citizenship
we understand your concern but there is
no need to worry for your inconvenience
your daily maintenance is reduced by two
to poke
the structure thank you
thank you i think i say thank you here
the structure congratulations you have
been accepted to the mind scanners
programming
enclosed is the needed equipment for the
job this includes a radio phone through
which you will receive further
instructions
the constructor thanks you for your
service for normality
and the mind smooches smooches xoxo with
all my love and all my body
the structure thank you
that means a lot can i see my daughter
oh hi
hi
[Applause]
your duty is to diagnose and treat
anomalous citizens of the structure
okay for each completed treatment
you will receive 15 cup out if you can't
pay maintenance at the end of each day
you will be exiled from the structure
and thrown into the outer zone
i don't know the outer zone seems kind
of dope i mean you hear anything called
the outer zone it sounds like a sick
club i don't go to clubs i don't know
[Music]
this map of the structure shows citizens
who have been shown signs of strange
behavior
look a citizen is in need of attention
go pay him a visit
do you want me to talk to this
broccoli-headed dude you know me and
talk to this guy
okay he lives in broccoli old henson
park the ventures district
the oldest park in the structure in the
home of many strange creatures take a
step
inside the outside i don't want to
rutger hoof
personality bar got a killer personality
i'm gonna go to this quote-unquote
patient
hey rootsters great start to this
conversation wish i never came here
swoosh
this citizen has already been scanned
his insanity amounted insanity types are
displayed here
good he's got three insanity
start treatment and remove his insanity
before time runs out
do i wonder dude what do i do what oh
hi all right let me scan you i
oh treatment oh
symptoms ah
[Music]
hello oh
yeah we got we got a lot of that
how about oh you want some goose
yeah take some of that goosh yeah your
personality's
dropping a bit but that's okay uh how
about we dial it into uh
ye old uh candelabra here
goosh how does that feel feel better
feel good oh yeah it feels good you
didn't need the personality anyway
you didn't look like you had much of
personality to begin with all right
goosh
all right there you go buddy you're good
as new rudy
treatment complete hey i got 15 kapoke
thanks thank you i'm
not an oak tree no that's sort of silly
isn't it
i guess i spend too much time with the
vegetation i better go visit my friends
again thank you
thank you so much you got it pal you're
welcome
good job mine scanner no more citizens
require your attention today
get some rest and continue tomorrow
i did it i'm the best my maintenance is
only seven kapoke
ouch your daughter is trapped in a room
you try to unlock the room but the key
breaks she screams
the frick is this is this a dream
all right fine three citizens require
your attention
who's a citizen before the mind scanned
unravelable their insanity
remember you take full responsibility
for their diagnosis oh do i
oh is that what i do oh okay oh hey
okay we got egyptian priestess we got a
triple hat
we got triangle man lady we got triangle
head
how's it going the hairstyles of barbara
are ever changing her unique methods and
hair styling have made her a fashion
icon
her clients include many many big
personalities but they are beginning to
cut her from their lives
okay that requires some travel time bert
is a simple-minded factory worker
no one has ever complained about him and
he is generally seen as a nice guy
lately his employer at the flesh factory
i'm just imagining the flesh factory oh
i'm imagining it
the slapping sounds of meat anyway
has been worried about his vivid
imagination yeah the people at the flesh
factory should be worried about his
vivid imagination formally known as
becky joe smith after replacing flesh
with implants she turned into christine
and quickly became one of our city's
most vocal
and extreme cyborg activists
okay so these are all kind of far away
from each other but i'm guessing i
should go to the farthest just to
start it off i guess i i'm guessing
you're not here for a haircut
jeez first my client stopped coming and
now they sent for you
i mean they know what they were in for
when they stepped inside my salon
i'm an artist expect an artist barbara
looks at her little finger
studying it okay let me just scan your
head there
don't mind me okay doc so i'll tell you
what i see on the screen
hope you can make sense of it let's
begin okay
i'm guessing you know how to do this and
i definitely don't
palace of divine my beauty parlor
transform and transcend you will never
be the same
extreme makeover
oh looks like my apartment
before i trimmed it down that is why do
we only trim our hair
most things look better way better after
a trim my sofa is a prime example
or fine art always so unbalanced
cuts anything hairy apartment
cuts anything yeah
miguel and patricia my two colleagues we
used to work together in the boots good
times
they are very conservative in their
style so i quickly outgrew them
they even criticized my method nowadays
sheesh
individual shared footwear individualist
individualist there we go
[Music]
nothing stops barbara from following her
desire to cut something down
hair flesh objects or paintings if her
intuition tells her it's off balance it
will be trimmed down
well that's a little uh that's a little
insane
i can see how that would be a slippery
slope this is so
weird having to declare someone insane
or insane i don't like the moral
implications of me just
having this power but it's the structure
and i'm
on a mission to see my daughter
apparently so thou art insane
sorry scissors
cicerosis
scissors you've been diagnosed with
scissors
i'm sorry oat wack oatwack
scissors removes one insanity point of
any type
psychotron weird are you ready for
treatment
initializing insanity paddle oh very
insane
very insane initializing stress bar
okay initializing personality bar okay
patient stats initialize i got a bad
feeling about this i'm gonna mess this
up your brain's gonna turn into goop
scissors how am i supposed to get new
clients with that diagnosis
i'm an artist not a lunatic there's a
difference but you too
[ __ ] conservative to see this aren't
you oh
that finger don't cut off your finger
your finger is fine barbara looks at her
little finger with spite
don't cut off your little finger your
psychotron treatment device seems to be
unstable aboard the red areas where you
will stress your patient
okay if you want to develop another
device use the left panel to access
device
manager or
choose a device that matches the
insanity type of your patient
the luna sucker removes up to three in a
row of insanity type
sucks out the strange energy of your
patient i'm gonna go with the luna
sucker just because that sounds
find the sweet spots
okay use the knobs the skin will wiggles
the
most at the sweet spots
okay how about we
just go for it treatment
here we go i'm gonna find the sweet spot
i don't know where on your body this is
but here we go
the skin will wiggle okay that's peak
wiggling
i don't like this i can i just say i
don't like this
wiggling identified we're gonna
suckatron it out of there
oh three in a oh
oh oh okay we're going for it
i didn't quite get it all there we go
i guess i could just do it all with this
i suppose i know this probably doesn't
feel too good but uh
shut up nailed it i'm the best
that's why they hire me for this job not
because they took my daughter from me
and i'll burn the whole organization of
the structure from the inside out
but because i care about my patients
hi why on earth was i thinking of
cutting off my finger
oh should probably take a step back my
style got out of control
oh my i just followed my passion
thank you for making this clear doctor
did i help did i not help i don't know
if i actually helped here but kind of
maybe
i don't know not saying the structure is
good by any means but whatever
okay all right let's see what this guy's
well okay i guess i gotta
i guess i'm done for the day i don't
know how do i do any more
end day there we go do you want to end
the day yeah
i think it might have been good that i
went to the far place because the other
two were kind of close to each other
therefore i could have
i could get them both in the same day as
opposed to the one that's far away you
know what i mean
i'm back in business baby i sent a bunch
of products to some of my most
um interesting projects and they forgave
me
i can't thank you enough i sent you a
bottle of my finest product
sure why wouldn't i open it you open the
small package
it contains the beauty product divine
intentions it makes your skin
surprisingly smooth
all right i'll take that thank you
the structure we are keeping your
daughter at the institute for further
examination
letting her return home would be
dangerous for her and everyone around
her
she is doing well you have nothing to
worry about she is an
interesting subject you should be proud
for normality and the mind
love and smooches and kisses and hugs
the structure
all right palace of divine you know i'm
okay
oliver zinsky bert herbert oh you guys
are farther away than i remember you
being
all right i'm going to go to bert
because that's who i was going to go to
before
so let's just go see bert hey bert how
are you doing burp
bird herbert has a visitor bird herbert
says hi
visitor must be quiet [ __ ] little man is
sleeping
little man is very little little man
sleeps in the left armpit of burt
herbert
hey bert let's scan that little brain of
yours
oh a slice of the flesh worm delicate
says boss
disgusting says bird herbert and little
man
best friends uh repel boss is best
friend
he's repelled
okay i don't know if that's correct or
whatever people little man is shy
hides from people little man only talks
with bert herbert
talks about apples and pumpkins little
man has how many apples and pumpkins and
out his own
vertebra doesn't know
invisible friend
yeah outer creatures favorite tv show
little man and bird herbert watching
together eat lots of candy
lovely creatures fun and beautiful
little man
falls asleep makes bert herbert smile
comforting
[Music]
i don't know if i did that correct bird
is now using the full potential of his
brain
this has led to a lonely life as a
factory worker his shy spirit has
created an invisible friend
a friend that keeps him company a friend
he cares for but
a false friend i declare he is insane
companionalis companionless
he's got companion linus get ready to
get treated
bird herbert is sick i understand it's
all right little man
dr skander will fix me you
you know buddy you know it i guess i'll
just
uh sure
okay easy now wait why is it not
hello can i not hello oh sorry wrong one
easy peasy
wait what's happening what's happening
i'm running out of time here oh i do not
like the undulation by the way
some people might like the undulation i
actually do not like the undulation
[Music]
sure wish my thing was working properly
nailed it i'm the best i'm the best that
i've ever lived ever
in the history forever treatment
complete hey you're doing good man
how you feeling wake up big guy wake up
i'm i'm bert herbert yes but i
i'm alone little man does not exist
he was just my imagination oh that's
no i'm never gonna see him again
oh little man i miss you oh
no oh oh oh
wait dog
[Music]
uh
oh boy we know that the structure is
keeping your daughter from you
we can help you and we believe you can
help us as well
just remember to take good care of your
patients
don't break the people break the
structure
moonrise kind of name is moonrise
do you think that's cool it's kind of
cool actually end of day three
[Music]
i can see how people would compare this
to papers please a bit
that's like a moral implication of it
and greater like city thing
this is mrs herbert you treated my
birdie he's changed
he's acting like a normal person
i miss his vivid imagination perhaps
he's a better field in your world but
not in mind oh but
i guess he was harm god damn it do i
have to
oh
i didn't even think about it that way i
didn't know that i was actually having
important decisions being made
i guess these are people's lives god
damn it he was harmless i
had a little friend but what does it
matter
oh greetings mind scanners have recently
been contacted by the terrorist group
known as moonrise these people seek to
destroy our society and must be stopped
have they contacted you
no hmm okay
if you receive a message from them or
any suspicious messages
you are obliged to tell us we will make
sure to protect you
for normality and the mind
the structure god damn it okay i gotta
make decision based on like
that's a butt it's a butt it's a butt i
gotta make decisions based on like
what i think is right you know what i
mean but i guess in a weird way i do
have to keep enough money to keep going
i gotta
see my daughter again greetings cyborg
no
are you interested in a pamphlet it's a
light read i have them here somewhere
sure i'll take one christine hands you a
pamphlet
the colorful cover reads cyborgs are
humans too
a 10 step guide on how to become one
with machines
the mechanicus the adept is mechanicus
you flip it open the first page reads
they might be your neighbor
your vidscreen repairman or even your
lover
cyborgs live in peace all around us yet
many people are still afraid of them
sorry i need to scan you just a
formality well that makes me a little
nervous
gotta say but okay i guess
don't worry about it you have nothing to
hide dance lessons
everyone had to take them in my district
the talons
looks beautiful here in your helmet but
i sucked
my legs never did what my mind told them
to do
disappointed by her body
the sign we use on the door of our
secret cyborg club
the guys there they have some pretty
interesting ideas on how to deal with
the plain skin problem
no pain no gain extreme measures
the electric noodle robot waiter he's
probably trashed by now
but when i was a kid i used to think you
look so satisfied with your existence
values makes life which is fine
totally valid christine has developed an
inexplicable hate for non-cyborgs and is
fighting a cause to transform every
citizen into a cyborg
by any means necessary is this true
is this actually what it is because if
that is true that's a problem but
if this is just something that the the
system is saying that they have
but not necessarily what they actually
think then that's
like are you actually a danger like i i
who am i to judge
it's your mind but also
this is my job i guess
okay if you have an inexplicable hate
for non-cyborgs
but you are fighting oh you're fighting
a cause
you're fighting for a cause to transform
every citizen into a cyborg by any means
necessary now that's
not okay because you have a right to
become a cyborg but you can't force it
on anyone else and by any means
necessary sounds
god bad i don't know if this is all true
insane bam
i don't know why psygosis
ah they're not gonna be happy about this
what no did someone tell you to do this
this is unbelievable i'm trying to
spread the message of love and
understanding
don't you know that you're breaking my
mechanical heart
but it didn't seem i don't know what's
true
i don't know what's true or false
i don't know what's true or false i
don't know
anything who moves up to three in a row
of insanity types closely
locates counts and eliminates
threatening patterns all right let's go
for them
ooh count these symbols input the
correct quantity
press and hold to search tidy up the
mind by locating counting and
eliminating threatening patterns press
and hold the search button to reveal
symbols and count how many symbols match
so on there's a play
okay cool there's also this one which i
could do
technically i have time for i think turn
to match sequence confirm
button run sequence the sapphires will
return zignocha charged audio waves
directly through the ear holes of the
patient
look out for the rhythm turn the knobs
to match the long notes of the sequence
okay i don't know what that means but
let's go for it i guess
sorry pal
what on earth is that uh don't ask you
don't want to know let's get those
jiggly bits going surprised you still
have jiggly bits
hang on whoa maybe i don't have time for
this
go baby go
okay uh okay wait play it again
two
[Music]
i don't know if this is faster i really
don't know if it's faster
[Music]
wait let's just go with this i don't
have time for this ah
i don't have time for this at all i
might not get this
oh my god i hate this i might not get
this i got to be like perfect
[Music]
oh my god i gotta be perfect
oh my god don't do that oh my god please
please please come on
nail it nail it nail it nail yes
come on go baby yes
one second left i destroyed your
personality
it's all gone to dustpoof and the wind
sorry about that i got a little excited
there and i don't know if i should be
very happy about this moment
playing skins i welcome you for
normality in the mind
i forgot to mention a minor side effect
of your treatments they sort of
reduce the personality of your patients
once the personality is completely
removed it can never be recovered
in the words you'll get paid either way
their insanity is first priority
it must be removed at any cost
do not listen to the structure you need
to take care of your patients do not
remove their personality
keep treating a treat with care oops
i am probably not doing too great
i'm not doing the best i could ever do
by my flesh you roast our leader you
brainwashed christine
[ __ ] plain skin we will turn you into
a pile of meat
um
[Music]
keep your eyes open when the time is
right we will talk again
accept any birthday invitations
moonrise don't don't play this like
presentable liberty or anything like
that
if i recall there was a bit of a
birthday invitation that didn't go too
well
who are you people appraised game
designer richard del romeo is most
famous for his digital card game power
hand
the best-selling video game in history
his pride has reached new heights as he
is planning to go into politics that
makes sense
steffie sparkle's familiar face can be
seen on ads and products all around the
structure
despite her success a bitterness seems
to grow inside her her behavior may
influence our citizens
so it's time to act oliver zinski is a
facts enthusiast we can all learn from
looking at data
but all of rozinski's insistence on
following facts and logic
has become a hindrance to his social
performance social performance you say
what if all of you out there had to have
a certain social performance quota
i mean you could kind of call that with
like social media these days but what if
it was
mandated by the government that you had
to do a certain amount kind of nuts to
think about but maybe it's not too crazy
whoa look at this place whoa this big
whoa that is
complex that's a lot of places
okay i'm going to end this episode here
but i do want to play more of this
because there is kind of a moral dilemma
going on here do you destroy someone's
personality
for their own good who am i to make
these choices
i have no idea but the game's kind of
fascinating and i do want to see more of
it
so let me know what you thought down in
the comments below thank you everybody
so much for watching
and i know i've mentioned it before but
we have a podcast called distractible
bob wade and i we do it every monday new
episodes come out
and if you haven't listened to any of
them listen to one today they're all
pretty good
if you've already listened to
distractible help me out by writing in
the comments what your favorite episode
was to try to guide people
to something to listen to it's a good
time you can get some
housework done or something while you
listen to it it's really fun i'm glad to
be doing something with bob and wade so
check it out
thank you everybody so much for watching
and as always i will see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you